wir beide geschichtsschreiber denn die
ganze schweiz das ist erfolgt
wir schreiben geschichte drinnen
[Musik]
dieser film handelt von einer
brasilianischen einwanderin die
schweizer geschichte schreiben will
wie wir an obenauf ist profi boxerin mit
schweizer lizenz und noch viel mehr
mutter auf high heels leidenschaftliche
kellnerin gewieft der unternehmerinnen
sozial engagiert ein kämpferherz
sie gibt viel dafür ihren traum leben zu
können
[Musik]
im august 2008 10 hatte vivien oben
darauf den feind ihres lebens sie
gewinnt gegen die engländerin und
favoritin natascha john s ich habe
gesagt ich muss gewinnen ich bin mit
meinen gedanken nicht zum geldverdienen
nicht zu einkassieren und nach hause
gehen
ich muss gewinnen ich habe keine angst
vor mir einmal gehabt nie einmal indes
vor befreien
[Musik]
hier zieht durch technisches ko
und meine familie so stoss mein papa
unglaublich mein vater hat geweint ich
von meiner mutter bisschen alles so
glück und stolz auf mich dass ich diese
weggenommen haben aber was mir wichtig
das sind die falschen menschen die mir
geglaubt habe wie nämlich kritisieren
haben weißt du das ist mein traum ich
habe mal gesagt ich werde eine boxen ich
kam da sie möchten dass und jeder kann
die spiele und dann haben wir jetzt das
funktioniert warum bloß das funktioniert
weil ich nicht aufgegeben habe und er
will immer noch größer erneut nicht an
dich glaubt dass auf jeden fall jetzt
mache ich zeige dich zeitlich drei
wochen sind seit diesem kampf vergangen
obenauf wartet jetzt auf die einladung
zur revanche
so ist es im profi boxen üblich aber ich
bin sicher sie werden ihre titel wieder
haben möchte
aber ich habe keine angst ich hab keine
angst habe ich habe angst arm zu sein
die habens krank zu werden ich habe
angst keine tag auf kopf zu haben
ich habe vor da sei es aber nicht für
eine frau seit obenauf vor vier jahren
vom olympischen boxen auch amateurboxen
genannt zum profi boxen gewechselt hat
kann sie mit ihren schnellen fäusten
auch geld verdienen
als alleinerziehende mutter nicht ganz
unwichtig verdient ein gegner und es
kommen geht jetzt noch postina hubert
6000 euro brachte die 31-jährige von
england nach hause nach hause an den
brienzersee zu calvin ihrem
siebenjährigen sohn mit rund 4 kämpfen
pro jahr als frau in der schweiz ist es
praktisch unmöglich vom boxsport leben
zu können wie wir an obenauf hat drei
verschiedene jobs kümmert sich mit ihrem
ex mann zusammen um den sohn und
trainiert nebenbei für die großen kämpfe
man muss machen
das hat mein vater mir beigebracht hat
gesagt willst du etwas erreichen das
lapd angeht arbeite diese leute die
gerne hauptsaal punkte die rechnung
sonst bist du einfach niemand
das ist wahr und so rennt sie täglich
notabene in high heels von job zum kind
zu training um ihren traum vom boxen
leben zu können
achtung stufe seit zwei jahren besitzt
sie in interlaken ihr eigenes gym
angefangen hat alles vor sieben jahren
nach der geburt ihres sohnes als ich
schwanger war
alles was ich wollte war das schön
es gab die konsequenzen ich war haben
mich ja nicht
es scheine schocken profile für viele
moderne was passiert mit unseren
schwangerschaft um die schwangerschafts
pfunde wieder loszuwerden fing sie an zu
boxen und konnte nicht mehr aufhören
nach zwei monaten wollte sie bereits
einen wettkampf bestreiten haben
wirtschaft gemacht habe gewonnen haben
mit boxee box die schon 18 jahren in die
schweiz geboxt haben ja wie geil war ich
war unglaublich als profiboxerin hat wie
wir noten auf bisher 17 kämpfe
bestritten und nur vier davon verloren
nach dem erfolg in england hofft sie nun
auf weitere attraktive kampf angebote
sodass ihr marktwert in der boxwelt
weiter steigt
doch so steil ihrer boxkarriere auch
sein mag alles auf diese eine karte zu
setzen wäre der brasilianerin zu
waghalsig in bern arbeitet sie 50% im
service es ist anstrengend macht müde
aber diese gesang dass wir nur jetzt
dass sich diese weise zeit und
vielleicht boxee nach fünf jahren nicht
mehr
dann muss sie als wickel richtig gas
geben und darum diese losheim ist für
mich richtig haben am pizza bestellen
ich habe extra geschult extra scharf an
die saale die leute mich kennen wir uns
nach von mir boxen werden es auf der
straße mein manager jung
es macht spaß
im boxkeller gegenüber dem restaurant
trainiert oben auf jeweils vor einem
großen kampf hier glaubt man an sie
wobei mit dem segen england hat selbst
der manager nicht gerechnet
die ja nicht serien passiert die boxerin
keine frau
und vielleicht quartier war ganz
filigrane technik aber katheder
karlsruhe und wird so ist so ausgegangen
ist herzlos als die gegnerin wird
eingestanden bringt wieder überraschen
gabor wird er ist ex profiboxer und oben
aufs trainer
[Musik]
er würde sie lieber im boxkeller
antreffen als hier ein monate war noch
nie war ein einziger training gerne noch
nicht wieder davon dass du wieder da
bist jetzt fällig
[Gelächter]
für ihren optimismus ist und auf bekannt
nein eigentlich meine meinung nach war
sie noch nie richtig fit
sie ist nicht hatte beruflich ein boxer
den erweiterten der b30 der eigenen box
schule sie hat ein kind zu hause würde
sie öfter trainieren wäre sportlich noch
mehr möglich so der trainer
doch die wahl schweizerin lässt sich
nicht gerne reinreden in brasilien
aufgewachsen hat sie mit 21 eine reise
nach europa gemacht um den basel ihren
ex mann kennengelernt
ihre familie hatte sich einen anderen
weg für sich vorgestellt
dies sind
gebildet augen
viele meinen dass sich anwälte und meine
schwester meine blutige ich war ein jahr
an der uni
aber das kommt ja ich wollte eigentlich
mediziner machen wo ist mein papa
glücklich machen
das war nichts für mich aber
ja das ist so wie ich bin ich kann nicht
sache machen das waren wir heute
gefahren
was sagt klingt das so ich muss freude
haben bin ich auch etwas in freude haben
dafür einfach davon das ist meine
schwache
der schweiz ist sie noch nicht davon
gelaufen seit zehn jahren ist hier ihre
neue heimat anders in brasilien die
armut die in gewissen regionen herrscht
erträgt obenauf nicht deshalb sammelt
sie in der garage eines ferienhauses
gebrauchte kinderkleider und bringt sie
einmal im jahr bedürftigen familien in
ihrer alten heimatstadt armut gab es
einfach so viele mannheimer die ag 2
wenn du dort bist du hast nicht große
möglichkeiten zu helfen und gegen die
wiener dort lebst du findet das alles so
normal
du siehst es ganz anders als wenn du
hier bist
hey wenn das war ein kinder gehen weißt
du wie sie freude habe ihr habt keine
schön und ich freue mich wenn ich das
mache ich immer um sich die reise nach
brasilien leisten zu können putzt und
betreut sie solche ferienhäuser ein
weiterer job
die profiboxerin ist sich für nichts zu
schade
abends gibt sie fast täglich training in
ihrem eigenen box lokal das ist mein
geschäft immer mein stolz stolz auch auf
einen sport bei dem sich zwei menschen
mit den feuchten die köpfe einschlagen
herausforderung kampf gefühl nicht
schlägerei das geht nicht wenn man
einfach schlägt man bekommt dann aber
kam verein feiert schön gutes gefühl wie
ein tiger
ihre begeisterung für den kampfsport
steckt an
gerade auch mädchen und frauen die den
großteil ihrer kundschaft ausmachen kann
ich kann da wilders in berlin gelernt
aber die haben wir sagen ganz so während
sion ist
[Musik]
sobald sie eine einladung zur revanche
in england erhalte werde auch sie wieder
mit seriösem training beginnen
doch wochen und monate vergehen und
keine einladung trifft ein bis im
november dann plötzlich alles anders
kommt wie wir an obenauf hat ein kampf
angebot erhalten
nicht gegen die engländerin at&s jonas
soll sie boxen sondern in paris die
vierfache meisterin im superfedergewicht
der international boxing federation
herausfordern wichtigste verband vom
boxen der älteste auch um die 46 toll
dass es zu mir kommt ich weiß sie werde
größer branche habe und sie möchten auch
eine harte kampf sehr werden setzen wir
zwei frauen boxen dauert zu lange
für die letzten tage vor dem showdown
lässt sie ihren ehemaligen trainer aus
berlin einfliegen
obenauf hat rund einem monat intensive
vorbereitung hinter sich physisch ist er
gut drauf psychisch dass ihr großer
vorteil je stärker wir müssen noch die
einen kleine technische variante
arbeiten womit war ihrer gegnerin
überraschen können und wenn wir das noch
hinkriegen sich optimistisch das wird
aber schwer
40 fieber hat von das hat während aber
nichts vor eine sportlerin ding steht
wie dieser mensch wiegen die hauptgefahr
keinen respekt habe auf jeden fall aber
sie ist will gleich
[Musik]
das ist sie ihre gegnerin die französin
marie warmer dusche nummer eins auf der
weltrangliste von boxing rekord am
morgen des files müssen beide zum wiegen
antreten
eine gewisse obergrenze satz macht
überschritten werden
[Musik]
der kampf findet erst am abend statt die
profiboxerin hat ihre eigene strategie
wie sie mit dem druck umgeht dass man
sie gar nix sowieso immer weg für diese
leute seien frische luft sei es nicht so
viele engel
das haben sie heute wachsen müsse wie
können davon auf
abgeschafft es gut
[Musik]
ich bin drei kilo fast je schwerer sie
ich muss das einfach ganz positiven eine
weile das bedeutet bin ja mein pass
sollte stärker seiner seele hoffe ich
auf eine famose gott will die gedanken
kreisen trotz ablenkung und boxen und um
ihren sohn calvin der sich vor jedem
kampf sorgen um seine mami macht ein
boxkampf wo ich wieder ich habe mich
sehr verletzt und seid da sei es ein
bisschen skeptisch geworden auf seine
letzte wurde wurde gestern war mama du
darfst verlierers bin ich sauer auf ich
habe bisher ja macht das nicht ich darf
nicht verlegen
tschüss ausmachen
[Musik]
b
rub al khali recht und ist meine ganz
okay
ja bist du von mir ganz okay
[Musik]
die letzten stunden bis zum kampf
verbringen obenauf und ihr team in der
garderobe beim bandagieren sind ein team
mitglied der gegnerin und ein vertreter
des boxverbandes dabei das normal
fußball boxen matchmaker sofort
interessiert weniger das verletzungs als
das finanzielle risiko bei einem solchen
kampf werde alles geben auf jeden fall
nicht big man kann mir nicht kaufen das
ist ja das sage ich bin nicht hier wegen
das geld das geld so etwas schönes aber
man box nicht wegen geld das ist für
mich prostitution
[Musik]
hopsten
[Applaus]
[Musik]
der ausschuss
warum
erlangen
die sieger haben
wer diese funktion
[Musik]
es fängt gut an die fäuste fliegen
wie wir an obenauf kämpft mutig drauflos
und steckt tapfer ein
doch nach der fünften runde gibt sie
plötzlich auf
[Musik]
dadurch gewinnt den weltmeistertitel des
ibf zum fünften mal nicht getäuscht
aber das ist gut und die grenze zwischen
bühne und man merke das ja kann
vielleicht gefällt werden und vom 26 das
ist aufgebraucht
später wurde bestätigt obenauf hat sich
in der vierten runde zwei finger
gebrochen
[Musik]
ich bin glücklich habe nicht mit nur
einer faust lässt sich keine schweizer
geschichte schreiben doch die
kämpfernatur wird weiter boxen nach
kurzer verschnaufpause wieder mit beiden
fäusten
[Musik]